la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué il n'y a pas
d'observation le procèsverbal est adopté
sous les réserves
d'usage l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen
des crédits de la mission immigration
asile et intégration du projet de loi de
finance la parole est à Madame Marie
Carole rapporteur spécial de la
commission des
finances ministre n'étant pas arrivé
nous allons prendre quelques
secondes
on vous
attendz très bien donc madame
senttu monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre chers
collègues l'examen des crédits de la
mission immigration asile migration
s'inscrit cette année pleinement dans
l'actualité l'actualité migratoire tout
d'abord puisque notre pays connaît une
très forte hausse du nombre de
demandeurs d'asile le gouvernement
s'attend en effet à 160000 demandes
d'asile en 2024 c'est environ 20 % de
plus qu'en 2019 année qui porte pourtant
le record historique de près de 133000
demandes l'actualité internationale
ensuite notamment avec la poursuite de
l'accueil en France des personnes
déplacées d'Ukraine du fait du conflit
avec la
Russie l'actualité de notre assemblée
enfin avec l'adoption le 14 novembre
dernier du projet de loi sur
l'immigration dans une version
significativement améliorée par rapport
au texte initial sur ce point il est
d'ailleurs évident que l'exercice
d'analyse du présent budget présente
quelque chose de malaisé cette année en
effet par construction le budget de la
mission a été établi sans prendre en
compte les modifications que porte le
projet loi immigration notamment
s'agissant des modifications apportées
par le Sénat il nous appartient donc
finalement ici d'analyser les crédits
pour ceux qu'ils sont il n'est
d'ailleurs nullement besoin de reprocher
au budget de cette mission de ne pas
intégrer des modification à venir de la
politique d'immigration et d'intégration
pour constater ces trop nombreux écueils
même en l'état du droit d'un point de
vue général les crédits de paiement sont
en hausse d'un peu plus de 7 % soit 150
millions d'euros supplémentaires ils
s'établissent à 2 milliards 16 d'euros
si l'on y regarde de plus près les
crédits proposés présentent quelques
petites améliorations mais aussi de
sérieux défauts parmi les petites
améliorations l'on peut noter des
efforts supplémentaires proposés
s'agissant des crédits dédiés au centes
de locaux de rétention administrative
pour les étrangers en situation
irrégulière l'on constate également de
petites Hauses de crédit dédié à
l'éloignement des migrants en situation
irrégulière et à la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine mais en sens
inverse les écueils du budget de la
mission sont beaucoup plus
nombreux le premier travers de ces
crédits c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
complets et qu'ils manquent de
lisibilité en effet comme l'année
dernière le budget prévu n'intègre pas
les dépenses si à l'accueil des
personnes déplacées d'Ukraine par
ailleurs quasiment la moitié des
dépenses de la mission transit par des
associations dans des conditions qui
échappent aujourd'hui trop largement à
la connaissance du par parement il
faudra y
remédier le deuxième écueil concerne la
dotation au titre de l'ADA la docation
pour demandeur d'asile pour 2024 son
montant serait en baisse de 21 million
d'euros pour s'établir à 294 millions
d'euros une telle prévision est
sous-estimée en effet elle repose sur un
objectif de raccourcissement des délais
de traitement des demandes d'asile par
l'OFPRA qui manque de réalisme en
particulier
face au nombre de record de ces demandes
c'est à forori le cas dans un contexte
de mouvements sociaux à
l'OFPRA le troisème écueil du budget
concerne les résultats obtenus sur la
base des crédits demandés chaque année
je prendrai la l l'exemple de la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière pour
donner un seul chiffre moins de 11500
retours forcés de personnes en situation
irrégulière ont été exécuté en 2022 soit
un niveau inférieur de 40 % à celui
constaté en 2019 et ce alors même que la
pression migratoire est aujourd'hui plus
forte ce nombre de retours forcés
exécutés a même été plus faible en
2022 que sur chacune des années de la
décennie
2010 enfin le 4e et dernier travers du
budget de la mission et sans doute le
plus grave est structurel
comme les années précédentes les
équilibres entre les différents types de
dépenses ne sont pas bons alors que les
dépenses fé à l'asile représente 2 tiers
des crédits les crédits d'intégration
n'en représentent qu'environ 1/5e et la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
un diè or une politique d'immigration
réussie doit garantir à la fois le
renvoi des étrangers en situation
irrégulière et l'intégration effective
des personnes autorisées à rester en
France c'est une question de bon sens et
d'acceptabilité sociale de
l'immigration en ne garantissant pas cet
équilibre le budget de la mission rate
finalement sa cible et ce d'année en
année en conclusion les crédits de la
mission ne répondent finalement au
besoins en matière d'immigration et
d'intégration ni en l'état du droit ni
dans celui que le Sénat a construit pour
pour l'avenir il y a quelques semaines
la commission des finances propose le
rejet des crédits de la mission je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
boncarè en remplacement de Madame
Murielle jourd rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des lois vous avez 3
minutes 3 minutes ou
oui monsieur M respect monsieur le
Président Madame le ministre mes chers
collègues je vérifie auprès de vous que
j'avais deux fois 3 minutes puisque
effectivement j'intervenais j'interviens
en lier place de ma collègue madame
Jourda corapporteur que je vous prie
d'excuser et pouvoir effectivement
bénéficier de mon temps de travail de
mon temps d'expression
traditionnel minut pardon on y va pour 6
minutes nous sommes d'accord monsieur le
Président on arrive à la même conclusion
euh madame la ministre le le budget
asile
immigration ressemble un peu au R cissif
pour le
gouvernement nos conclusions sont à peu
près toujours les mêmes nous proposerons
un avis défavorable à ce budget tout en
mesurant les difficultés de l'exercice
et qu'il s'agisse de l'exercice dans la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
chacun le sait les résultats ne sont pas
brillants il y a un découplage croissant
entre l'édiction de mesures
d'éloignement et leur exécution nous
savons que malgré l'augmentation des
capacités d'accueil d'hébergement nous
sommes encore loin de répondre aux
besoins et plus
généralement toutes les procédures
d'éloignement sont soit trop lentes soit
trop réduites les résultats ne sont pas
beaucoup plus brillants sur la politique
de l'asile
avec un effort considérable qui a été
fait au niveau de
l'œufpra qui si on nous compare par
rapport à les autres pays européens
l'herbe du voisin n'étant pas plus vert
au moins dans ce cas fait que nos délais
de traitement sont plus rapides que ceux
de nos collègues européens mais malgré
tout ce sont des résultats très fragiles
puisque avec l'augmentation
importante de l'immigration rappelé par
ma collègue il y a quelques secondes
nous avons de nouveau une remontée des
délais au niveau de l'offra vous dire
également que les prévisions du
gouvernement nous paraissent à cet égard
assez optimiste en ce qui concerne le
versement de l'allocation dite
Ada au regard d'une diminution
prévisible des délais de traitement par
l'ofpr le gouvernement avait espérer une
baisse du niveau des allocations nous
craignons que cette prévision ne puisse
se réaliser nous avons donc des
résultats en demiteinte résultats en
demi-teinte que l'on retrouve aussi en
matière
d'immigration dans d'intégration pardon
euh on peut considérer comme pertinente
le renforcement récent des services des
étrangers tout en vous c'était quelque
chose d'attendu si on veut régler
notamment améliorer les situations pour
les prises de de rendez-vous et plus
généralement pour le fonctionnement de
la politique d'intégration mais vous
dire en même temps que le renforcement
des services des préfectures se fait
largement avec des contrats actuel se
fait largement avec des personnes qui
n'ont pas forcément la connaissance la
technicité et qu'enfin nous gardons un
désaccord avec votre administration pu
qu'avec le le ministre et avec vous-même
votre administration peine à lâcher le
contrôle dont elle bénéficie grâce aux
quelques 180 titres de séjour avec
chaque fois des conditions d'admission
particulière l'inconvénient étant que le
nombre de type de séjour rentre
extrêmement complexe l'application de
ces dispositions rendra encore plus
aléatoire l'examen de ce que nous
appelons le le
360 le
360° donc nous vous redisons que cette
question d'études de séjour révocation à
être réexaminé quand j'évoque ces
difficultés de faire fonctionner des
services étrangers dans la préfectures
je pourrais l'élargir à lffi qui a plus
particulièrement cette mission
d'intégration en prenant une seule
donnée chers collègues le taux de
rotation à l' F est d'environ est
d'environ 37 % c'est chiffre qui nous a
été donné pour le dernier exercice ça
veut dire que la totalité du personnel
de l'OFI se trouve renouvelé sur un
espace de 3 ans dans ces conditions il
est diffic difficile d'acquérir des
compétences spécialisées dans des
métiers qui ont pourtant du sens et qui
sont importants c'est dire que nous
allons déception en déception d'où notre
avis défavorable sur l'adoption des des
budgets quel que soit encore une fois
les efforts réalisés je voudrais
terminer ce propos en évoquant deux
points de manière complémentaire le
premier pour vous dire Madame la
Ministre chers collègues que nous avons
choisi de faire un focus dans notre avis
budgétaire sur quelque chose qui est peu
souvent évoqué qui est celui des accords
internationaux et en particulier traité
avec l'Algérie de 68 85 94 et 2001 vous
dire mes chers collègues qu'à ce stade
nous souhaiterons aller beaucoup plus
loin dans la l'examen de ces éléments
dans le dans le détail il est difficile
de se faire une appréciation vraiment
déterminante sur la pertinence au notre
pays de ces conventions si je prends les
pays les conventions avec l'Afrique de
l'Ouest qui sont intervenus sous la
présidence Sarkozi il peuvent être
extrêmement différents nous avons l'URE
présente 110 accords internationaux et
avec l'Algérie il y a indiscutablement
des éléments qui paraissent pertinents
et d'autres qui le sont moins
le les accords avec l'Algérie marquent
essentiellement des accès en terme de
séjour et de circulation plus favorbl
pour les ressortissant algériens à
l'inverse moins favorable sur d'autres
éléments je pense en particulier du fait
qu'il n'y a pas d'accès au titre de
séjour plurannuel comme il n'y a pas de
procédure de type passeport talent avec
l'Algérie vous dire également qu'il y a
un impensé à ces dispositions sur
la sur les questions pénal les
binationaux algériens et
franco-algériens sont nombreux l'Algérie
n'extradant pas ses ressortissant ça
veut dire que poures les AFF toutes les
affaires de trafic de stupéfiants
pouvant concerner des franco-algériens
il n'est pas possible de mettre à
exécution les mandats d'arrêt qui
peuvent être adressés voilà très
rapidement les observations que je
souhaitais faire tout en ayant bien
envie de commencer à évoquer le travail
mené à l'Assemblée nationale la
commission des lois mais nous aurons
d'autres occasions merci monsieur le
rapporteur dans la suite de notre
discussion je vous rappelle que le temps
de parole attribué à chaque groupe pour
chaque unité de discussion comprend le
temps d'intervention générale et celui
de l'explication de vote et par ailleurs
le gouvernement dispose au total de 10
minutes pour intervenir la parole est à
Monsieur philippe Tabarot pour les
républicain pour 5
minutes
merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues l'examen de cette mission
intervient alors que les problématiques
migratoires ont plus que jamais retenu
l'attention des Français du législateur
il y a moins d'un mois nous discutions
du projet de loi immigration
actuellement en cours d'examen à
l'Assemblée nationale et la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle de notre groupe
abordera bientôt également la question
nous sommes donc au cœur de l'actualité
or au regard de l'ampleur de ces enjeux
l'effort budgétaire consenti par cette
mission demeure endessa de nos attentes
comme on pu l'exprimer les rapporteurs
en donnant leur avis défavorable au
crédit le compte n'y est pas après la
parenthèse de la pandémie la tendance à
la hausse des flux plus de personnes
entrant sur le territoire depuis une
vingtaine d'années aussi bien légalement
qu'illégalement s'est confirmé ici c'est
la problématique des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui interroge tout
particulièrement sur notre capacité à
mener à bien nos politiques en matière
migratoire par exemple le nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'AME a dépassé 400000
en 2022 soit une hausse de près d'un/ers
par rapport à 2016 bien entendu les
négociations autour du pacte européen
sur la immigration et l'asile se
poursuive au sein des instances de l'UE
de même que l'examin du projet de loi
immigration en France mais attendre un
retournement de la tendance paraît peu
raisonnable à court terme il est
indispensable d'agir or les crédits
fléché au sein du programme 303 vers la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
ne représente qu'une fraction assez
minime des crédits de cette mission 12 %
soit 260 millions d'euros cette
faiblesse relative de l'effort financier
contribue probablement à la faiblesse
des indicateurs et notamment des taux
d'exécution des OQTF situés en desessà
de 7 % depuis 2020 en outre bien que
nous saluons l'extension graduelle de la
capacité d'accueil des centres de
rétention administrative prévu le
passage d'environ 1850 places en 2023
dans l'Hexagone à 3000 places en 2027
tel qu'envisagé par la lompie semble
difficilement concevable en suivant la
trajectoire actuel il y a un réel risque
d'effet ciseau entre le nombre de places
et celui des personnes mises en
rétention comme le lcin de la remontée
des taux d'occupation en passant à la
question des politiques d'asile
commençons par saluer la réduction du
délai de traitement des demandes qui a
atteint au moyen 311 jours en septembre
dernier cependant il ne faut pas oublier
que cette réduction des délais n'est
sans doute pas sans lien avec le trou
dans les arrivées pendant la pandémie et
que les progrès ainsi réalisés pourraent
être rapidement perdus dans un contexte
de reprise rapide du nombre de demandes
concernant le versement de la location
pour demandeur d'asile nous partageons
le constat des rapporteurs sur
l'existence d'un manque de
sincérité en effet si les crédits
affectés affichent une baisse faciale et
des hypothèses prudentes sur la
progression des demande d'asile ils
excluent les versements effectués aux
personnes déplacées ukrainiennes
bénéficiaires de la protection
temporaire or ces versements
représentent s'il en figurait une part
substantielle de la dotation au titre de
la D pour ce qui est du programme 104
intégration et accès à la nationalité
française nous constatons qu'il reste en
retard par rapport au besoins malgré une
hausse de ces crédit l'an passé haosse
par ailleurs non reconduite or
l'intégration par la langue notamment
est une composante essentielle de la
politique migratoire dont le
renforcement a d'ailleurs été voté par
le Sénat le mois dernier et leur
dynamique ne saurait être découplé de
celle des flux eux-mêmes au risque de
mal intégrer voire de ne pas intégrer
sans entrer plus loin dans les détails
nous dressons une fois de plus le
constat d'une politique d'asile et
d'immigration menée au fil de l'eau qui
ne se dote pas des moyens de maîtriser
la situation ce dont pâtissent à la fois
les Français et les étrangers résidants
en France la mission immigration asile
et intégration n'est donc pas à la
hauteur des enjeux politiques des enjeux
humains ou encore administratifs inérant
à ces questions pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons et comme l'an passé le groupe LR
suivra la position de rejet des
rapporteurs et ne votera pas les crédits
de cette mission merci cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur emmeric Durox pour
3 minutes du groupe des
noninscrits
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues samedi soir le terrorisme
islamique a encore frappé dans notre
pays un touriste allemand a été tué
alors qu'il visitait notre capitale avec
son épouse deux autres passants ont été
attaqués avant que le terroriste ne soit
neutralisé par des policiers ce
terroriste a un nom Arman rajapour
miandoab il a un parcours ses parents
avaient fui l'Iran desmola la France a
accueilli sa famille l'a élevé nourri
lui a donné un espoir une possibilité de
s'émancip il a choisi de nous remercier
en ce la mort et la désolation il y a
quelques semaines sa mère avait
d'ailleurs signalé son comportement à la
DGS mais rien n'avait été fait par le
ministère de l'Intérieur la
responsabilité du ministre doit être
aujourd'hui questionnée certes hélas
trois fois hélas cet individu est
français né en France comme s'est
empressé de rappeler le ministre de de
l'intérieur mais il a omis de préciser
comme toujours que cet individu est
d'abord et avant tout issu de
l'immigration de culture musulmane comme
97 % des auteurs d'attentats terroristes
depuis 2015 les dernières attaques
d'aras à Hansi en passant par
Rambouillet nous le rappelle
douloureusement le lien entre
immigration et terrorisme islamique et
donc nul n'en doutait d'ailleurs
malheureusement éloquant il est aussi
d'ailleurs en matière d'insécurité du
quotidien selon les mots même du
président de la République qui disait le
26 octobre 2022 sur France 2 je cite on
ne peut pas ne pas voir que la moitié au
moins des délinquants des fêtes de
délinquances qu'on observe à Paris
viennent de personnes qui sont des
étrangers soit en situation régulière
soit en attente de titre pour être plus
précis selon le service statistique
ministériel de la sécurité intérieure en
Île-de-France 93 % des mises en cause
pour des vols sans violence dans les
transports en commun Transilien et 81 %
de ceux pour des vols avec viol sur ce
réseau sont identifiés comme étrangers
par ailleurs dans notre pays un détenu
sur quatre et de nationalités étrangères
sont compter tous ceux qui sont
d'origine étrangère la situation est
donc catastrophique et que propose le
gouvernement face à cela encore plus
d'immigration comme en témoigne son
budget 2024 de 7,9 milliards contre 7,1
milliards en 2023 soit une hausse de 11
%. tous les budgets explosent et
illustrent la volonté du gouvernement de
ne pas contrôler l'immigration alors que
le récent projet de loi immigration
débattu sur ces bancs qui n'était certes
pas la panassée mais contenait quelques
mesures de bon sens a été soigneusement
vidé de toute sa substance en commission
à l'Assemblée nationale par l'alliance
des macronistes de la gauche et de
l'extrême gauche les résultats pour
lutter contre cette immigration massive
sont quant à eux ridicules alors
qu'environ 80 % des demandes d'asile
sont finalement déboutté par le fra seul
10 % desutf sont exécutés d'ailleurs la
plupart des terroristes qui ont
ensanglanté notre pays était soumis à
des TF qui n'ont pas été exécutés ce
n'est pas une ligne comptable qui
réglera ce problème vital de
l'immigration dans notre pays et nous ne
voterons évidemment pas en faveur de ces
crédits pour le régler définitivement il
faudra faire appel au souverain suprême
le peuple comme nous nous y engageons
depuis des années par l'organisation
d'un référendum sur la question
migratoire comme l'immense majorité des
Français le réclame depuis des années
les Français veulent sortir de ce
cauchemar et nous les arons je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à Madame Vania paroli gagin du
groupe les indépendants pour 4
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues à n'en pas
douter l'immigration est un sujet
politique majeur après avoir voté un
projet de loi d'ampleur nous examinerons
dans la foulée du budget un projet de
loi constitutionnel visant à proposer
des solutions pour les difficultés que
nous
connaissons les crises géopolitiques
s'enchaînent
en Europe en Afrique et au Moyen-Orient
ces tragédies alimentent des
déplacements de population notamment
vers l'Europe nous observons depuis
plusieurs années déjà un fort
accroissement des flux
migratoires en 2022 les franchisements
illégaux de la frontière extérieure de
l'Europe ont bondi de 64 % par rapport à
2021 ils ont encore augmenté en 2023 au
sein de Frontex la France et ses
partenaires européens doivent déployer
davantage de moyens pour faire face à
cet
afflux l'immigration légale connaît elle
aussi une forte progression au sein des
pays de l'OCDE 300000 immigrés
permanents en France pour la seule année
2022 un chiffre qui bat le record de ces
15 dernières
années nos capacités d'accueil sont
malheureusement limitées nous devons
déterminer quels étrangers sont admis à
à rester sur notre
territoire notre groupe souhaite que ce
choix s'opère au travers de contingents
déterminés par le
Parlement la dignité et l'efficacité
nous commande d'apporter des réponses
rapides aux
étrangers personne n'a vraiment intérêt
à ce que les procédures traînent en
longueur ni les intéressés ni notre ni
nos finances
publiques les dispositions du projet de
loi immigration devraient permettre
d'accélérer les procédures et donc de
réaliser quelques économies il nous faut
éviter absolument l'augmentation du
nombre de personnes ne pouvant être ni
régularisé ni
expulsé depuis trop longtemps maintenant
madame la ministre les obligations de
quitter le territoire français sont trop
peu
exécutés nous savons que vous travaillez
à palier cette carence il faut
absolument y parvenir en se fixant une
obligation de résultat pour la 4e année
consécutive
le taux d'exécution est inférieur à 7 %
nos concitoyens ne peuvent pas le
comprendre lorsque l'intéressé ne
s'exécute pas volontairement nous devons
avoir les moyens de l'y
contraindre pour cela il faut poursuivre
le travail que vous avez engagé madame
la ministre en concluant des accords de
réadmission avec les pays d'origine afin
d'obtenir les incontournables laisser
passer
consulaires jugeant que les
augmentations budgétaires étant
insuffisantes au regard des qui nous
attendent la commission du Sénat a émis
un avis défavorable au crédit proposé
par le
gouvernement nous sommes pour ce qui
nous concerne convaincu que la question
migratoire est essentielle pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et plus
encore pour ceux des territoires les
plus
exposé je pense par exemple au
territoires ultramarins comme Mayot où
une pression considérable met à mal le
PACT
républicain l'intégration constitue
également un sujet majeur sur lequel
nous devons tous investir pour assurer
la cohésion de notre nation les défis
sont immenses mais la France ne peut pas
les relever seul l'Europe doit apporter
des solutions avec l'adoption du pacte
asile et
immigration même si l'immigration
pourrait bénéficier d'un budget plus
important le groupe Les Indépendants
votera en faveur de l'adoption de ces
crédits je vous
remercie merci la parole est à madame
Isabelle Floren du groupe UC pour 6
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre Monsieur Madame et monieurs les
rapporteurs et mes chers collègues le
projet de loi de finances pour 2024
consacre la transition écologique comme
une priorité absolue comme le réarmement
des services publics la lutte contre la
fraude la la réduction des déficits
publics et encore la lutte contre
l'inflation mais n'aurait-il pas fallu y
ajouter ajouter à cette liste des axes
prioritaires la politique d'immigration
et d'intégration au regard des débats
que nous connaissons depuis plusieurs
mois à ce propos résultant notamment
d'une forte accélération des flux
migratoires certes les crédits de la
mission sont en hausse en crédit de
paiement de 147 million d'euros mais les
autorisations d'engagement sont elles en
baisse de 34 %. certes la mission a
connu des évolutions de périmètre cette
année les crédits de paiement
apparaissent alors comme la le meilleur
indicateur de l'évolution des crédits en
2024 mais en neutralisant les effets de
périmètre ces crédits sont en hausse de
d'environ 5,4 % soit une augmentation de
109 millions d'euros mais les
autorisations d'engagement restent quant
à eux dans une dynamique de baisse or au
moment où nous engageons nous nous
engageons à faire des changements
majeurs dans notre législation
concernant l'immigration n'est-ce pas le
moment d'augmenter les autorisations
d'engagement et non de les baisser je
suis consciente que la présente mission
ne représente qu'une part minoritaire
des crédits de l'État dans ce domaine
qui est évalué à 7,9 milliards d'euros
pour 2024 mais le renforcement de notre
législation doit s'accompagner d'une
vision budgétaire pour l'avenir le
périmètre de la mission est composé de
deux programmes connaissant tous deux
des évolutions budgétaires significative
le programme 303 immigration et asile
bénéficie d'une hausse de ses crédits
euh de plus de 259 millions par rapport
à 2023 cette hausse est liée à une lutte
contre
l'immigration irrégulière et à la
poursuite du plan d'ouverture de place
en centre de rétention administrative
pour atteindre progressivement 3000
places en 2027 contre
1490 en 2017 il faut relever également
que les crédits demandés au titre de ce
programme n'intègrent pas de même que
l'année dernière les dépenses relatives
à l'accueil des bénéficiaires de la
protection temporaire en provenance du
crème estimé à
95000 le programme France visa qui je le
rappelle est le système permettant de
dématérialiser la procédure
d'acquisition et d'instruction des
demandes de visa et d'externaliser la
constitution des dossiers notamment dans
la pays dans les pays où la demande est
la plus forte pourrait-il voir ces
moyens notamment
augmentés je voudrais également
m'attarder plus particulièrement sur la
dématérialisation des procédures de
dépôt et d'instruction des demandes de
titre de séjour les rapporteurs et je
les rejoins sur ce sujet soulignne leur
son intensification et elle est positive
mais force est de constater que les
demandes de prise de rendez-vous sont
encore trop longues et la plateforme
très souvent saturée notamment dans les
départements franciliens par ailleurs
même si des renforts en personnel
notamment vacataire ont été fournis il
reste encore trop insuffisant dans
certaines préfectures au service
d'accueil des étrangers comme les
rapporteurs d'ailleurs l'ont souligné
enfin le programme intégration et accès
à la nationalité française portant sur
les crédits d'intégration des étrangers
primau arrivants et des réfugiés connaî
une double be celle des autorisations
d'engagement ainsi que celle des crédits
de paiement une double baisse de 20 %
alors qu'un effort budgétaire doit être
selon nous porté d'une façon plus
générale et en partageant en cela l'avis
de mes collègues de la commission des
lois et ceux de la commission des
finances le budget de cette mission ne
répond pas au défis en matière
d'immigration et d'intégration auquel
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui et
encore plus demain le vote de notre
groupe sera donc défavorable je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
guaroche du groupe écologie solidaire et
territoire pour 4
minutes président bonjour
a monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues après le PGA immigration
et intégration nous avons l'occasion de
voir comment le gouvernement accompagné
budgétairement ses politiques d'asile et
d'immigration pas de surprise ce budget
traduit la bascule sécuritaire de la
vision des mouvements migratoires cette
dérive au-delà de son aspect idéologique
se fait au détriment d'un meilleur
accompagnement des nouveaux arrivants au
détribment de leur accès au droit au
détrimment de l'intégration que ce
gouvernement avait annoncé pter j'ai eu
l'occasion de le répéter les coupes
budgétaires sur l'allocation pour
demandeur d'asile sont très révélatrices
et très préjudiciables non seulement
celles de l'année dernière Mo 36 % avait
été fallacieusement justifié par le
changement de règles à venir sur le
droit d'asile en 2023 qui n'a pas eu
lieu d'ailleurs mais s ajoute cette
année une diminution de 10 %. comment
pensez l'intégration sans l'autonomie
sans capacité pour se loger pour se
déplacer pour se soigner pour se nourrir
pour s'éduquer c'est absurde la priorité
du gouvernement reste la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière d' acte mais
cette politique repose sur une jambe
l'augmentation encore et toujours des
places en centre de rétention
administrative rétention administrative
qui s'apparente de plus en plus à une
détention rétention administrative qui
est encore admise pour les enfants dans
la loi en dépit des ne9u dernières
condamnations de la France par la CEDH
notre groupe pense que les millions
alloués pour multiplier le nombre de
placements en rétention alors que des
des éloignements ne sont pas
matériellement possibles et que les octf
se multiplient sans effet traduisent
toute l'absurdité et le manque de
discernement de cette politique sur
l'immigration petite lumière isolée le
début de la prise en compte des
problématiques de l'hébergement je
rappelle souvent au gouvernement la
promesse d'Orléan du président de la
République qui en juillet 2017 déclaré
je ne veux plus d'ici la fin de l'année
avoir des hommes et des femmes dans les
rues dans les bois je veux partout des
hébergements d'urgence promesse non
tenue encore toujours de paroles les
chiffres disponibles concernant
l'hébergement font état de la création
de 1000 places en 2024 dans 500 dans des
centres d'accueil pour demandeur d'asile
et 500 dans des centres d'accueil et
d'examen des situations ce qui dem
insuffisant car en 2024 de nombreux
demandeurs d'asile continueront donc de
solliciter un hébergement en dehors des
structures d'accueil et notamment au
sein des structures d'hébergement
d'urgence de droit commun qui sont déjà
nous le savons tous saturés le
gouvernement continue d'organiser la
désorganisation
organiser les défaillances de la CNDA
qui manque de moyens et de personnel et
en même temps justifier une réflexion
sur les modifications des règles de
droit afin de limiter les recours en
argant que les délais de réponse sont
trop longs augmenter l'aspect
sécuritaire de la politique migratoire
et en même temps rendre plus difficile
les prises de rendez-vous en préfecture
pour l'obtention des titres à cet égard
je rappelle que le tribunal
administratif de Paris a condamné l'OFI
et la préfecture pour la mauvaise
gestion de la plateforme téléphonique de
prise de rendez-vous destiné au
demandeur d'asile il leur en outre
intimé l'ordre de rendre son numéro
gratuit et de mettre en œuvre des
mesures afin qu'il soit répondu plus
rapidement aux appels où sont les
crédits pour cela où sont les crédits
permettant d'avoir en nomme suffisant
les personnes pour répondre aux
demandeurs d'asile ces délais ces
défaillances ont d'ailleurs je le
reconnais bien été perçu par la majorité
sénatoriale qui parle de ouvre les
guillemet procédure longu et complexifié
pour de nombreuxes alléas techniques
dfonctionnement du site TLS contact peu
de rendez-vous disponibles et cetera et
a donc décidé de changer les règles mais
attention seulement pour les citoyens
anglais propriétaires en France serait
une immigration sansitaire l'obsession
de l'aspect sécuritaire perdure d'or
pour ce gouvernement il en deviendrait
presque caricatural s'il n'était pas si
drmatique dans ses conséquences l'action
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière a
connu une trajectoire budgétaire
impressionnante entre 2017 et 2021 avec
une augmentation de 60 68,1 % des
crédits c'est à mettre en regard à la
baisse significative des crédits de ceux
sur l'intégration 24 % dans la même
période c'est révoltant moins
d'intégration réussie mais pas plus de
réussite face à l'immigration
irrégulière la situation demandere un
budget reflétant une vision humaine et
réaliste de toutes les préoccupations
liées à l'asile et à l'immigration celle
de l'accompagnement de l'effectivité de
l'accès au droit de l'intégration c'est
loin d'être le cas c'est même l'inverse
notre groupe ne votera pas ce budget
cauchemaresque merci chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur brossa du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
kanaki Monsieur Merci Merci monsieur le
Président Madame la madame la ministre
ce débat nous le tenons dans un contexte
bien particulier celui où va être
débattu en séance publique à l'Assemblée
nationale le projet de loi immigration
qui nous a beaucoup occupé ici également
au Sénat et au fond les divergences qui
nous nous opposait au gouvernement au
moment de ce débat n'ont pas disparu
aujourd'hui au moment de de débattre des
crédits de de cette mission au fond le
débat il est de savoir si nous pouvons
faire sans l'immigration ou si nous
considérons qu'il faut faire avec parce
que les flux migratoires sont
inéluctables dans un monde où les
difficultés en matière sociale en
matière climatique sont de plus en plus
importantes et dès lors c'est notre
conviction que nous considérons que ces
flux migratoires sont n luuctable que la
France devra prendre sa part notre
conviction à nous celle qui anime notre
groupe c'est qu'il faut s'organiser à
dessin et c'est que la question centrale
devient la question de l'intégration de
notre capacité à faire de ceux qui
viennent en France ceux qui cherche
refuge en France des Français
et nous considérons que les crédits de
cette mission nous nous permettent pas
de relever ce ce défi en effet les
programmes qui connaissent la plus forte
baisse madame la ministre dans ce budget
sont précisément ceux qui sont dédiés à
l'intégration les crédits consacrés à
l'hébergement et ce du plan de
traitement des foyers de travailleurs
migrants aujourd'hui la moitié des
demandeurs d'asile n'ont pas les
propositions d'hébergement auquel ils
ont droit pourtant cela a été dit à
l'instant par mon collègue le budget qui
nous est présenté acte un nouveau retard
dans l'hébergement des demandeurs
d'asile avec seulement 1000 nouvelles
places prévues en 2024 contre 4900
annoncé pour 2023 cette prévision est
insuffisante elle est préoccupante dans
un contexte de très forte tension sur le
parc global d'hébergement notre groupe
propose d'ailleurs un amendement pour
augmenter significativement le nombre de
place d'hébergement créé en outre dans
ce texte le projet annuel de performance
sur l'apprentissage du français pour
l'intégration des migrants et très flou
nous avons besoin d'évaluation sommaire
des efforts consentis et des résultats
obtenus pour pouvoir comprendre les
besoins et l'impact de ces programmes
enfin j'aimerais vous alerter nous
alerter collectivement sur la stabilité
du montant de laallocation pour
demandeurs d'asile Lada qui soulève des
questions au regard du nombre de
bénéficiaires et du montant de
laallocation en particulier à la lumière
de l'augmentation des dépenses
contraintes des foyers en période
d'inflation je rappelle ce chiffre laad
c'est 6 € par jour pour une personne
seule et cette personne par définition
en tout cas en l'état actuel du droit
j'espère que ça changera n'a pas le
droit de travailler au cours des
premiers mois de l'examen de sa demande
c'est pourquoi notre groupe proposera
une revalorisation de cette aide ainsi
la politique migratoire prévue par ce
budget confirme ce que nous constatons
depuis 2017 une dégradation des
conditions d'accueil et d'accompagnement
et des atteintes répétées aux droits
fondamentaux notamment concernant
l'hébergement surtout cette orientation
budgétaire soulligne la priorité donnée
à la répression et à la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière au détriment
des actions visant l'intégration et
l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile les
chiffres parlent de même la politique
migratoire est aujourd'hui centrée sur
le mauvais accueil la restriction et le
contrôle pourtant cette politique du
chiffre est tous les jours soumise à un
échec patent au contraire notre groupe
croit qu'il est impératif de faire avec
l'immigration en prenant la juste mesure
des mouvements de population en
régularisant les travailleurs sans
papierers et en favorisant la mobilité
géographique des familles immigrées
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
groupe votera contre ce
budget merci chers collègues la parole
est à Michel Masset du groupe RDSE pour
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame messieur les rapporteurs
chers
collègues voilà donc un budget que nous
examinons entre deux autres textes le
projet de loi immigration qui aura fait
parler
euh du Sénat et pour différentes raisons
de mon point de vue et une proposition
de loi constitutionnelle qui devrait
elle aussi faire l'objet de discussion
ouleuse dans notre
hémicycle tout montre à mes yeux une
forme de
paradoxe nous allons consacrer à peine 2
heures à l'examen de cette mission alors
que
au regard de notre ordre du jour le
sujet est
fondamental notre pays fait donc face à
des pressions budgétaire importante nous
sortons d'une crise sanitaire qui a
beaucoup mobilisé nos finances publiques
il y a maintenant une crise énergétique
une inflation qui impacte fortement nos
concitoyens et ces pressions budgétaires
V valent également en matière d'asile et
d'immigration chacun le sait les coûts
associés à l'accueil l'hébergement et
l'intégration de ces femmes de ces
hommes de ces enfants sont très
importants il ne faut pas
leigner dans les grandes lit de ce
budget que
constatons-nous la mission voyit ses
moyens augmenter ces dernières années
cela se poursuit légèrement en 2000 pour
l'année
2024 sur certains aspects pourrait-on se
satisfaire par exemple nous saluons la
création de place d'hébergement pour les
demandeurs d'asile et réfugiés
vulnérables qui se poursuit en 2001 24
avec 1500 places supplémentaires dont
500 pour les réfugiés
vulnérable et plus largement nous nous
réjouissons d'un budget qui favorise en
priorité l'asile mais également pour une
part significative la politique
d'intégration l'action numéro 12
intégration des étrangers Primot
arrivant connaît cette année une hausse
de ses crédits c'est une bonne
chose mais nous l'avons dit il y a
quelques semaines l'une des clés de
réussite en matière d'immigration passe
par l'apprentissage de la langue
française l'accès au droit et
l'accompagnement vers l'emploi des
personnes étrangères
euh pour autant nous restons vigilants
concernant les moyens accordés à
l'Office français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration le financement total par
l'OFI qu' une baisse de 40 millions
d'euros nous comprenons que cette
diminution ne devrait pas impacter les
moyens de l'OFI de celle-ci mais
résulterait d'une baisse euh d'une
baisse de versement de la location pour
les demandeurs
d'asile madame le ministre il faudra
demeurer vigilant dans les années à
venir pour cette tendance que cette
tendance ne se poursuive pas je dirai
enfin un mot de la question de
l'immigration irrégulière qui pose
évidemment des difficultés à notre pays
ce but accorde des moyens en hausse pour
les dépenses d'investissement des
centres de rétention administrative des
locaux de rétention et des zones
d'attente certes mais je m'interroge
tout de même sur l'intérêt d'une Elos
pour participer à régler la question de
l' immigration irrégulière les mesures
d'enfermement se renforcent et
s'allongent depuis plusieurs années sans
montrer une véritable efficacité dans
l'application des mesures
d'éloignement nous sommes pas
spécialement contre c dispositif mais
nous demeurons dubitatif sur leur
pertinence lorsqu'il s'éternisent
d'autant que d'autant plus excusez-moi
lorsque nous savons que le service
actuel souffr de manque
d'effectif il faud donc observer comment
sera géré concrètement l'augmentation
des place dans les CRA bref chers
collègues notre groupe aura un avis très
partagé sur ces crédits avec toutes les
réserves que je viens d'exprimer merci
chers collègu la la parole est à
Monsieur Martin levvrier du groupe
RDPI pour 5 minutes chers
collègues monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances madame la
rapporteur spécial monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis mes chers collègues
cette mission incarne l'engagement du
gouvern vernement à maîtrisé les flux
migratoires à faciliter l'intégration
des étrangers en situation régulière et
à garantir l'exercice du droit
d'asile trois grands objectifs la guide
en
2024 premièrement la réduction des
délais de traitement des demandes
d'asile afin de redonner sa pleine
portée au droit d'asile le gouvernement
souhaite ramener à 6 mois en moyenne le
délai d'examen des demandes par l'Office
français de protection des réfugiés et
apatrid et par la Cour nationale du
droit d'asile depuis début de l'année
2021 les délis d'instruction des
demandes s'améliorent nettement mais
restent malheureusement éloigné de
l'objectif de 6 mois le renforcement des
effectifs de l'OFPRA devrait lui
permettre d'atteindre le délai de 60
jours fixé par le gouvernement
deuxièmement l'amélioration des
conditions d'accueil et d'intégration
des
étrangers le renforcement des capacités
d'hébergement a déjà porté ses fruits
faisant progresser la part des
demandeurs d'asile hébergés grâ
gratuitement de 45 à 73 % entre 2017 et
2022 en 2024 1500 nouvelles places
seront ouvertes contribuant à un
dispositif national d'accueil de
122582 places troisièmement l'efficacité
renforcée de la lutte contre
l'immigration
irrégulière conscient que le taux
d'exécution des obligations de quitter
le territoire français reste trop bas le
gouvernement s'engage à renforcer
l'effectivité des retours forcés par
ailleurs l'expérimentation de la force à
la frontière dans les Alpes Maritimes et
les Hautes Alpes ainsi que le
financement britannique des
540,3 milliards d'euros sont les
témoignages de sa détermination à lutter
contre les mouvements
secondaires en matière d'immigration
légale le gouvernement maintiendra son
attention sur l'immigration étudiante et
cherchera à rééquilibrer la part de
l'immigration professionnelle par
rapport à l'immigration familiale pour
l'intégration des étrangers en situation
régulière le
continuera à mettre en œuvre des
programmes visant à renforcer
l'insertion professionnelle linguistique
et civique c'est essentiel enfin le
gouvernement propose une série de
mesures dans le projet de loi
actuellement examiné par l'Assemblée
nationale visant à renforcer le contrôle
de l'immigration améliorer l'intégration
et garantir le respect des principes de
la République nous pouvons citer la
création d'une carte de séjour d'un an
travaille dans les métiers en tension
pour les travailleurs irréguliers dans
les secteur en
pénurie la mise en place d'une nouvelle
carte de séjour pluriannuelle talent
professionnel médical et de pharmacie
pour les praticiens diplômés hors Union
Européenne l'exigence d'un niveau
minimum de connaissance de la langue
française pour les étrangers demandant
une première carte de séjour
pluriannuelle la facilitation de
l'éloignement des étrangers représentant
une menace grave pour l'ordre public y
compris ce présent depuis longtemps ou a
ou ayant des liens familiaux en France
ensemble ces initiative témoigne de
l'engagement envers une gestion
équilibrée des flux migratoires une
intégration réussie et le respect des
droits fondamentaux notre groupe le
groupe RDPI compte sur votre soutien
pour faire de ces objectifs une réalité
et construire un avenir plus juste et
plus inclusif pour tous et rappelle qu'à
l'issue de de pardon du passage à
l'Assemblée nationale la commission
mixte paritaire du projet de loi
immigration représente une opportunité
cruciale de parvenir des résultats
tangibles en conciliant les différentes
perspectives et en élaborant des
solutions consensuelles je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Corine naraigin du groupe
socialiste 6
minutes chers
collègues
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous nous retrouvons
une nouvelle fois en peu de temps dans
cet hémicycle pour évoquer le sujet de
l'immigration après les débats intenses
que nous avons eu sur ce sujet il y a un
mois les crédits de la mission
immigration asile et intégration pour
2024 sont en hausse de 7,3 % mais c'est
encore bien loin d'une réelle prise en
compte des besoins et toujours
insuffisant pour permettre une véritable
intégration des personnes migrantes dans
notre pays ce budget est tout d'abord
marqué par une baisse de laallocation
pour les demandeurs d'asile qui passe de
314 mlion d'euros en 2023 à
293,9 millions en 2024 et cela alors que
le gouvernement attend en 2024 180000
demandes d'asile contre 135000 en
2023 contrairement à ce qui est avancé
une accélération des procédures à
l'OFPRA ne peut à elle seule justifier
ce net recul et cela alors que le PLF ne
prend pas en compte l'arrivée des
personnes ayant fui l'Ukraine la Cour
des comptes elle-même a vivement
critiqué ce choix de non budgétisation
en déclarant les besoins peuvent sembler
en effet difficiles à calibrer ceuxci
apparaissent néanmoins incontestable
compte tenu du prolongement du conflit
en Ukraine le défaut de sincérité
budgétaire est établi à cette égard de
plus madame la ministre nous aurions pu
comprendre cette baisse du montant de
laad si la DR sénatorial n'avait pas
supprimé l'article 4 du projet de loi
immigration qui aurait permis au
demandeurs d'asile de travailler dès le
dépôt de leur demande il a été
réintroduit en commission à l'Assemblée
et nous resterons vigilants sur son
maintien qui nous paraît
essentiel rappelons que le montant
journalier de laada est de 6,80 par jour
pour une personne il peut être majoré en
cas d'absence d'hébergement ce montant
dérisoire ne permet pas au demandeurs
d'asile de vivre dignement ni même de
manger à leur fin le leur permettre
d'accéder à un travail dès le dépôt de
la demande d'asile est aujourd'hui une
mesure de bon sens et je ne comprends
même pas que la droite de cet hémicycle
si soucieuse de nos dépenses publiques
soit
contre nous tenons à saluer la création
de 1500 places d'hébergement
supplémentaire pour l'année qui vient
mais cette création est largement
insuffisante alors que nous avons
aujourd'hui seulement 58 % des
demandeurs d'asile qui bénéficient d'un
émergement et une saturation des
dispositif il n'est pas acceptable de
laisser ses hommes ses femmes ses
enfants dormir sur nos
trottoir nous proposerons donc de créer
2000 places d'hébergement d'urgence
supplémentaire même si nous avons bien
conscience que cela demeure encore ins
suffisant concernant l'objectif de 3000
places en CR d'ici fin 2027 dont nous
devons la paternité à Eric cioti dans le
cadre de la lopmie c'est conforme à
votre politique un nombre toujours plus
important de personnes retenues pour des
durées toujours plus longues nous
saluons l'adoption en commission à
l'Assemblée de l'interdiction du
placement des mineurs de moins 18 ans en
cras mesure que nous avions déjà défendu
ici au
Sénat de plus monsieur Darmanin prétend
n'enfermer que les personnes dangereuses
dans les cras mais son interprétation
très large de la menace à l'ordre public
et le placement en rétention des des
étrangers dupliné qui découl du projet
de loi immigration le contrediront et le
sait nous tenons à alerter néanmoins sur
la présence de personnes vulnérables
dans lescas nous l'avions fait lors du
débat en hémicycle sur le projet de loi
immigration ces personnes souffrent
parfois de troubles psychiatriques et il
y a une nécessité de les
accompagner suite aux nombreuses alertes
de la Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté je tiens à rappeler
que la priorité doit être donnée à
l'entretien et à la réflexion des locaux
existants plutôt qu'à de nouvelles
constructions toujours dans le cadre du
projet de loi immigration vous imposez
une obligation de résultat en français
pour obtenir une carte de séjour
pluri-annuelle en prétendant que cela
participe à l'intégration mais nous
avons bien du mal à voir comment les
crédits relatif à l'apprentissage de la
langue sont répartis monsieur Darmanin a
déclaré en séance au Sénat nous
prévoyons d'augmenter de 9 millions
d'euros les moyens consacrés par l'OFI
au cours de français destinés aux
étrangers qui passeront l'examen de
langue que nous nous proposons de mettre
en place nous avons du mal à trouver ces
lignes dans les crédits nous aimerions
avoir plus de précision sur la
ventilation des crédits d'intégration et
ce et ce qui est plus particulièrement
consacré à la formation linguistique
madame la ministre augmenter le budget
c'est bien encore faut-il mener une
politique migratoire ambitieuse et digne
ce budget est la confirmation que le
projet de loi de votre gouvernement n'a
d'intégration que le nom pour ces
raisons nous ne ne voterons pas les
crédits de cette
mission merci la parole est à madame la
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté et de la ville madame la
ministre
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la Commission des ance
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
permettez-moi tout d'abord de saluer en
quelques mots nos forces de l'ordre pour
leur sang-froid et leur courage dans
leur action de samedi soir et évidemment
une pensée très émue pour les victimes
et les familles des victimes donc je
suis très heureuse d'être parmi vous
quand même ce matin pour vous présenter
les crédits de la mission immigration
asile et intégration quelques mois
seulement après le vote du Parlement
visant à octroyer près de 15 milliards
d'euros au ministère de l'Intérieur et
des outrmères à travers la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur la lopm sur les
CIN prochaines années je vous prie tout
d'abord de bien vouloir excuser le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres
mèes qui ne peut malheureusement être
présent aujourd'hui pour 2024 le
Gouvernement a souhaité vous présenter
un budget en augmentation de plus de 7
%. pour un montant total de 2,2
milliards d'euros en crédit de payement
soit environ 10 % des crédits du
ministère sur le périmètre de laalopmie
cette augmentation représente aura près
de 147 millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires par rapport à la loi de
finances 2023 elle inclut les crédits
issus de la lopm pour la période
2022-2027 plus 109 millions d'euros y
compris ceux du plan CRRA 3000 ce budget
marque une nouvelle étape dans les
efforts conduits depuis 2017 pour
consolider notre capacité à à maîtriser
les flux migratoires et lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière garantir
l'exercice du droit d'asile renforcer
l'intégration des étrangers en situation
régulière dit primo arrivant ce budget
s'inscrit pleinement dans le cadre de
laalopm avec une programmation
budgétaire inédite en 5 ans nous aurons
ainsi fait progresser les crédits
affectés à la mission et donc à la
politique migratoire de la France de
façon réelle et inégalée le programme
303 immigration et asile s'établit à
hauteur de 1,7 milliards d'euros soit
une augmentation de 17,7 %. cette
progression sensible reflète pour partie
le transfert des programmes numériques
et celui des places hébergements pour
réfugés précédemment assuré par le
programme 104 mais aussi 165 millions
d'euros de mesures nouvelles le
programme 104 intégration et accès à la
nationalité française s'établit pour sa
part à 431 million d'euros la diminution
des crédits de ce programme à peu près -
20,6 % par rapport à 2023 correspond à
l'essentiel au transfert que je viens
d'évoquer je veux par ailleurs souligner
que ce programme prévoit une
augmentation des places d'accueil en
et vous l'aurez noté il s'agit là d'un
rééquilibrage interne des actions
soutenues pour une plus grande
lisibilité mais sans incidence sur les
grandes orientations de la mission en
effet cette année encore près de 65 %
des crédits seront consacrés à l'accueil
à l'examen des situations des demandes
d'asile et des réfugiés les 1,4
milliards d'euros concernés doivent
permettre d'assurer les dépenses
d'hébergement à hauteur de 996 millions
d'euros les dépenses pour l'allocation
pour de demandeur d'asile à hauteur de
300 millions d'euros et les crédits
nécessaires au fonctionnement de
l'Office français de protection des
réfugiés et des apatrides à hauteur de
108 millions d'euros par ailleurs 20 %
des crédits soit 431 million d'euros
seront consacrés à la politique
d'intégration ce sont 260 millions
d'euros qui seront mobilisés pour la
maîtrise des flux migratoires en
complément des dépenses dédiées à ces
missions par les budgets de la police
nationale de la police aux frontières et
de la gendarmerie ce chiffre comprend
notamment les crédits alloués à la
politique des visas à l'aide au retour
ou encore au financement des lieux de
rettention naturellement mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ce budget 2024
n'inclut pas les crédits qui seront
rendus nécessaires par les mesures du
projet de loi pour contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
actuellement en discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale que vous avez adopté le 14
novembre dernier il n'intègre pas non
plus se rendu nécessaire par l'accueil
et l'accompagnement exceptionnel des
bénéficiaires de la protection
temporaire qui ont fui l'Ukraine au mois
de mars début 2022 je veux souligner ici
que la France accueille aujourd'hui
environ 73000 personnes dans cette
situation à contrario ce budget intègre
la prise en charge des coûts de la
revalorisation salarial décidé par le
gouvernement en septembre 2022 afin que
les salariés du secteur privé non
lucratif bénéficient de l'équivalent de
l'augmentation de la valeur du point
d'indice de la fonction publique cela
représente environ 19, 4 million d'euros
sur la mission sur le fond je tiens à
redire avant tout l'engagement total du
gouvernement pour une politique
migratoire plus efficace mais aussi plus
humaine je tiens aussi à vous présenter
en quelques mots les grandes lignes des
principales évolutions des crédit de la
mission en matière d'asile nous
souhaitons continuer à améliorer
l'accueil et l'examen des situations des
demandeurs au total
138577 premières demandes ont été
enregistrées en 2022 soit un niveau
proche de celui de 2019 année où la
demande d'asile avait été la plus
importante en France depuis le début de
l'année 2023 la hausse de la demande
d'asile s'est poursuivie elle atteint à
peu près plus 8 % mais le niveau de
cette augmentation moins haut que et
moins haut que le reste de l'Europe qui
est proche lui de 30
%. aussi dans un contexte de fortes
incertitudes et de tension
internationale le gouvernement a établi
cette programmation en anticipant la
possibilité d'une une demande de l'ordre
de 160000 demandeurs d'asile en 2024
pour un montant global de 300 millions
d'euros au titre de la loocation de
demandeur d'asile
Lada en complément nous entendons
maintenir les 500 places dédiées au Sass
d'accueil temporaire créé dans 10
régions de métropole pour accueillir les
personnes sans solution d'hébergement ou
de logement prise en charge dans le
cadre d'opération de mise à l'abri en
matière d'intégration ensuite nous
souhaitons poursuivre les efforts depuis
5 ans ceux-ci ont déjà permis une
augmentation du niveau d'exigence en
matière d'apprentissage linguistique et
civique en matière d'immigration enfin
nous permettrons et nous mettrons pardon
en œuvre un dispositif refondu d'aide au
retour volontaire l'ARV plus incitatif
via une dégressivité dans le temps du
montant dans le temps du montant de
l'aide pour accélérer les éloignement
nous poursuivrons également
l'augmentation très nette de nos
capacités de rétention dans le cadre
fini par la lopm pour porter le nombre
de places en centre de rétention
administrative à 3000 d'ici 2027 soit le
double des 1500 places existantes fin
2017 je veux souligner que le ministre
de l'Intérieur et des outres mèes a
récemment annoncé l'implantation de 10
nouveaux cras avec sans place chacun les
efforts en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine seront ainsi
réhaussés de 90 millions d'euros pour
atteindre 261 millions d'euros en 2027
en 2024 nous consacrerons donc également
près de 15 Millions d'Euros pour
renforcer nos moyens matériels dédiés en
procédant à l'achat par exemple
d'intercepteur moyen de projection ou en
constituant un étatmajor dédié mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs j'ajoute que
le gouvernement déposera dans les
prochaines heures deux amendements
concernant l'OFI et l'OFPRA à l'article
41 qui n'est pas étudié aujourd'hui afin
d'adapter leur plafond d'emploi le
premier vise à augmenter le le plafond
d'emploi de l'Office français de
l'immigration et de l'intégration l'offi
de plus 10 ETP ces effectifs
supplémentaires ont déjà été accordé en
gestion en 2023 pour permettre à l'OFI
la mise en œuvre de l'aide au retour
volontaire dans le cadre de la stratégie
de desserrement des places d'hébergement
en île-de-fance et la création de SAS il
s'agit d'orénavant de les solder de les
saclcl pardon la le second vise à
augmenter le plafond d'emploi de
l'Office français de protection des
réfugiés des patriie de l'OF pr de plus
de plus de plus euh 8 ETP pardon en suus
des 17 ETP supplémentaires prévu par le
PLF 2024 dont 8 ETP euh à temps plein
pour les divisions de la protection
cette augmentation additionnelle fait
suite à un amendement déposé en première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale vous
pourrez toujours compter en tout cas sur
ma détermination et celle du ministre de
l'Intérieur pour vrer dans cette
ambition je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je vous rappelle que pour
cette mission la Conférence des
Présidents a fixé la durée maximale de
la discussion à
1h45 nous devrions donc en inter
terminer aux alentours de 11h45 afin de
pouvoir passer à l'examen de la mission
écologie développement et mobilité
durable ce qui paraît possible au vu du
nombre d'amendements et avec un rythme
relativement
soutenu nous allons procéder à main des
amendements portant sur les crédits de
la mission immigration asile et
intégration figurant à l'état B un
amendement du Gouvernement madame la
ministre amendement
oui
pardon très drôle monsieur le Président
donc effectivement un amendement du
Gouvernement donc qui propose de
rétablir les crédits supprimés en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
euh je le dis rapidement donc ce sont
les crédits supprimés à hauteur de moins
de000 €. en autorisation d'engagement et
en crédit de paiement sur l'action 3 du
programme 303 immigration et asile par
l'amendement
273 visant à ouvrir les cours de
français langue étrangère à tous les
étrangers en situation régulière qui en
font la demande et en deuxè an les
crédit supprimé à hauteur de Mo- 300000
€ toujours en autorisation d'engagement
en crédit de paiement sur l'action 11 du
programme
4 intégration et accès à la nationalité
française par l'amendement 2 2 24 40
pardon t 244 visant à reéhausser les
crédits octroyés à l'Office français de
protection des
réfugiés et des apatries de l'OF pr je
vous remercie merci avis de la
commission sur le fond cet amendement
est cohérent mais la commission des
finances proposant le rejet des crédit
de la mission elle ne peut logiquement
qu'en demander le
retrait je mets au voix
l'amendement avec une demande de retrait
de la commission qui vote
pour 5 3 8
10 qui vote
contre il est
adopté amendement 172 monsieur
rox mes chers collègues dans un objectif
gouvernemental de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques d'une part et U égard à la
pression migratoire qui s'exerce sur
notre pays d'autre part cet amendement
propose de supprimer les subventions
versées annuellement par l'État au 1350
associations qui agissent dans les trois
domaines de la présente mission
budgétaire la prise en charge du droit
d'asile en France de même que la
politique d'intégration a été
partiellement déléguée par l'État à ses
opérateurs associatifs
or si l'État veut reprendre le contrôle
de ses frontières et de ses dépenses il
est nécessaire de lui réassigner le
droit d'asile dès lors ces subventions
versées à ces opérateurs associatifs
sont sans
fondement avis de la
Commission selon les informations que
j'ai recueilli auprès de la Direction
générale des étrangers en France en 2022
1472 associations ont bénéficié de de
crédit via les deux programmes de la
mission pour un montant total d'un peu
plus d'un milliard d'euros s'agissant
des dépenses en lien avec l'asile que
vous mentionné ce sont 383 associations
qui étaient concernées pour plus de 900
millions d'euros ces dépenses consistent
principalement dans la gestion de
l'hébergement des demandeurs d'asile le
nombre d'associations et le montant
cumulé de ces subventions concernées
nécessite sans aucun doute que nous y
regardions de plus près néanmoins votre
amendement reviendrait à retirer la
quasi intégralité des crédits concernés
ce qui est très excessif et empêcherait
d'appliquer le droit en vigueur je vous
demanderai donc le retrait de cet
amendement comme d'ailleurs l'ensemble
des autres amendements de crédit puisque
la Commission Finances propose le rejet
des crédits de la mission avis du
gouvernement défavorable monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur donc
évidemment je suis défavorable à cet
amendement car les subventions sont
versées par le ministère de l'Intérieur
et des outres mèes à des associations
qui réalisent des missions de services
publics
elles ont répondu à des appels à projet
lancés au niveau national et au niveau
territorial à l'initiative des préfets
donc défavorable monsieur durx oui oui
c'est un en quelque sorte un amendement
d'appel hein mais je note avec plaisir
que le rapport de comment dirais-je de
la commission va va dans ce sens c'est
bien et je dirais pour répondre aussi à
madame la ministre que la plupart de ces
associations sont des associations
militantes qui encouragent en réalité
l'immigration qui la favorise qui l' et
ca donc je crois que l'argent des
Français qui exprime de plus en plus un
r vis-à-vis de cette pression migratoire
insupportable doit être entendu et donc
je crois qu'il faut supprimer une bonne
partie de de ces
subventions monsieur pas du tout pas du
tout je je le mtiens je le mtiens bien
sr cet amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas
adopté le 170 monsieur
dux
chers collègues l'objet du présent
amendement est simple réaliser des
économies nettes sur le coûteux
financement des centre d'accueil
s'adressant au demandeurs d'asile et de
la location demandeur d'asile en
divisant par deux les fonds alloués à
l'action qui leur est consacré la France
ne peut tout simplement pas se permettre
d'offrir à tous ceux qui prétendent lui
demander l'asile donc je rappelle que 80
% d'entre eux sont déboutés d'ailleurs
un traitement de leur cas sur son sol et
s'y contraindre ouvrant la voie à une
dérive incontrôlée de la dépense
publique c'est pourquoi le rassemblement
national propose depuis plusieurs années
moyennant une révision constitutionnelle
que les demandes d'asile soient
présentées en dehors du territoire
national dans les ambassades et
consulats et que les demandeurs puissent
être accueillis pendant le temps de leur
examen sur le territoire d'État s'il
vous plaît merci avec lesquels la France
aura conclu un accord à cette fin avis
de la
commission cet amendement rejoint pour
parti le précédent il s'agit de réaliser
de très fortes économies sur le le
logement des demandeurs d'asile et sur
la loocation pour demandeurs d'asile
encore une fois le montant proposé
apparaît excessif et empêcherait
d'appliquer le droit en vigueur demande
de retrait avis du
[Musique]
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
défavorable alors je suis défavorable à
cet amendement pour trois raisons
principales monsieur le sénateur tout
d'abord les dépenses prévues par la
garantie de l'exercice du droit d'asile
relève des obligations d'assurer auprès
des demandeurs d'asile des conditions
matérielles d'accueil CMA digne ensuite
le gouver verement engagé des mesures de
réduction du délai global d'instruction
des demandes d'asile enfin le taux
d'hébergement des demandeurs d'asile
c'est considérablement amélioré et
atteint 85 % en
2023 contre 59 50 % en 2017 grâce aux
efforts considérables qui ont été
effectués depuis 2017 pour augmenter les
capacités d'hébergement des demandeurs
d'asile cet effort permet de maîtriser
le coût de laallocation des demandeurs
d'asile Lada puisque la part
additionnelle n'est pas versée lorsque
le demandeur d'asile est hébergé et
enfin au global toutes ces mesures ont
permis de maîtriser les dépenses en
faveur de l'exercice du droit d'asile à
peu près 1 % en plus de hausse
uniquement entre le projet de loi de
finan 2024 par rapport à la loi de
finances initiale de 2023 hors mesure de
périmètre défavorable je mets au voix
cet amendement avec une demande de
retrait de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
monsieur Dosu pour le 754
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui fait suite à au débat
qu'on a eu pendant le projet loi
immigration sur la fuite en avant du
gouvernement dans l'extension de la
rétention administrative je va pas
rappeler ici le l'histoire de la
réttention administrative mais ce n'est
pas anodin que le l'amendement suivant
du rassemblement national soit l'exact
opposé puisque aujourd'hui les centres
de de rétention administrative sont
l'expression de d'une politique
d'enfermement aux mains de la
l'administration chaque année des
dizaines de milliers d'hommes et de
femmes sont internés dans des conditions
euh extrêmement dures voir plus dur que
la prison de la Ve même de celles et
ceux qui sont qui ont connu ces milieux
ces deux milieux et alors même que la
rétention il faut le rappeler n'est pas
la détention la rétention n'est pas une
peine et euh la moitié plus de la moitié
des personnes qui sont retenues ne le
sont pour rien puisque euh selon les
rapports mêmees annexés au PLF le taux
effectif d'éloignement des personnes
passées en Crass s'élève seulement à
43,2 % pour l'année 2022 ce qui signifie
que concrètement euh 56,8 % des
personnes ont été enfermées dans dans
dans ces centres pour rien euh ce n'est
pas acceptable et je voudrais alerter
ici aussi madame la ministre sur le le
la construction des nouveaux centres de
rétention puisque c'est cras du futur
comme ils sont appelés le premier a été
construit à Lyon on a été plusieurs à le
visiter je l'ai visité la bâtonnière l'a
visité plusieurs députés l'ont visité
des journalistes l'ont visit visité euh
la contrôleur général des privation des
lieux de privation de liberté l'a visité
et a même mis une équipe plusieurs jours
sur place pour constater comme nous tous
que ces crats sont déshumanisants et
extrêmement durs pour les les personnes
qui sont retenu qui sont c'est indigne
des standards de détention qu'on devrait
attendre d'une République comme la nôtre
et donc je vous alerte et je ne suis pas
le seul sur ces nouveaux cras et donc
nous estimons que le budget de ces
nouveaux cras serait mieux employé à
l'accueil des primos arrivants c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de transférer ce
budget à ce programme merci avis de la
commission nous avons en commun des
inquiétudes s'agissant de la création
des places dans les centres de rétention
administratif pour votre part vous
pensez que trop de places sont créées
pour ma part je m'inquiète à l'inverse
que l'on n'atteigne pas l'objectif fixé
de 3000 places à l'horizon 2027 et
j'aimerais d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement nous confirme que nous
aurons bien en 2027 3 mis places
disponibles et pas seulement financé
avis de
retrait avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre euh défavorable monsieur le
Président l'objectif du gouvernement est
de 3000 places en CR 2027 euh donc voilà
c'est c'est inscrit c'est validé
puisqu'on en avait discuté la dernière
fois et tout ça sanctuarisé dans les
prochains PLF sur les 3000 places en
tout cas prévu merci Monsieur Paco pour
explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Dosu se plain du caractère déshumanisant
des nouveaux cras je suis pas persuadé
qu'avec moins de moyens financiers on
aura des CRAT de meilleure
qualité merci Monsieur
Dosu les moyens ils ont été mis sur le
nouveau centre de rétention c'est
vraiment sa construction de type
pénitentiaire c'est vraiment une cage he
euh je vous invite à à aller visiter le
le centre de rétention de Lyon avant de
vous vous exprimer puisque c'est
vraiment sur ce modèle là que vont être
construits les nouveaux et je vous je
vous assure que euh ce n'est pas une
question de moyen c'est vraiment une
question de penser l'architecture comme
une prison ce qui n'est pas le le la
destination d'un centre de rétention et
donc vraiment je je retire la sonnette
d'alarme sur les conditions de
construction de ces nouveaux cras qui
sont vraiment indignes de notre
République merci je mets au voix cet
amendement avec une demande de retrait
de la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est pas adopté
monsieur Durox pour le
160 merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues en effet cet amendement est
l'exact opposé de celui déposé par mon
collègue écologiste nous sommes fiers
d'avoir une vision tout à fait opposée
une vision qui est conforme à
l'aspiration de la grande majorité des
Français pendant que nous nous nous
répondons à leur inquitude vis-à-vis de
l'immigration eux font passent leur
samedi soir à faire des boud thérapies
pendant qu'il y a un énième attentat
islamique en effet on est on n pas sur
la même longueur d'ongle et nous on a on
reçoit l'assentiment de la majorité des
français donc cet avendement en effet il
a pour but donc de de de dire que les
centres de rétention administratives
sont nécessaires en matière de lutte
contre l'immigration régulière cependant
leur taux d'occcupation a atteint 86,4 %
en 2019 et 80,9 en 2021 face à cette
situation il est urgent de donner des
moyens suffisants aux forces de l'ordre
pour affronter les flux migratoires
ainsi le présent amendement prévoit
d'abonder les crédits en autorisation
d'engagement et en crédit de paiement
d'un montant de 100 million d'euros
cette augmentation permettra de lancer
la construction de nouvelles places
supplémentaires dont nous avons grand
besoin avis de la
commission alors comme je viens de le
dire il est souhaitable que nous
augmentions le nombre de places de
centes de rétention néanmoins il ne faut
pas dépenser sans compter rajouter 100
millions d'euros ce serait sans doute
beaucoup avis de
retrait madame la ministre avis du
gouvernement avis défavorable à cet
amendement car le montant inscrit au
projet de loi de finances 2024 en faveur
de la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière est en augmentation de plus
54 % par rapport à la loi de finances
initiale 2023 et en quasi triplement
depuis 2018 cette progression donc au
PLF 2024 inclut les crédits programmés
par la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur laalop M visant à atteindre
3000 places de centre de rétention
administrative en CR en 2027 donc
défavorable je mets au voix cet
amendement avec une demande de retrait
de la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
monsieur Durox pour le
168 mes chers collègues chaque année
plusieurs filières d'immigration
régulière se livre au trafic de migrants
à la fourniture de faux documents et à
l'emploi d'étranger sans titre et elles
sont démantelé chaque année par exemple
un réseau criminel proposant pour un
montant de 15000 € toute une série de
faux documents passeport carte
d'identité permis de conduire fiche de
paix avis d'imposition contrat de
travail et autres à des personnes sans
papier afin de faciliter l'obtention de
la reconnaissance de droit sur le
territoire français a récemment été
identifié ainsi le présent amendement
prévoit d'abonder les crédits en
autorisation d'engagement et en crédit
de paiement d'un montant de 60 millions
d'euros afin de donner davantage de
moyens à nos forces de l'ordre pour
démanteler ces réseaux criminels je vous
remercie avis de la
commission alors je vais être très clair
les filières d'immigration irrégulières
sont effectivement un fléau contre
lequel il faut frapper fort d'une part
elles augmentent le nombre de personnes
en situation irrégulière sur notre sol
et d'autre part elles exploite le sort
tragique des personnes dans une logique
parfaitement criminelle des efforts sont
faits par nos services de police et
gendarmerie pour lutter contre ces Féo
il faut sans doute faire plus même si
cela ne passe pas forcément en premier
lieu par une hausse de crédit en tout
état de cause votre amendement
relèverait davantage de la mission
sécurité qui porte des crédits de la
police et de la gendarmerie y compris
s'agissant de la lutte contre les réseau
d'immigration irrégulière demande de
retrait avis de du
gouvernement
défavorable défavorable donc en matière
de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière ce sont 224 filières qui ont
été démantelées par l'action des
services sur les 8 premiers mois de
l'année par ailleurs je tiens juste à
préciser que le gouvernement a une
approche et on tient à le réaffirmer
équilibré en matière d'immigration entre
l'accueil des étrangers et la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière donc
défavorable je mets au voix cet
amendement avec une demande de retrait
de la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
je suis saisi de trois amendements dont
deux identiques 680 monsieur bar roche
monsieur le Président le présent
amendement du groupe écogist solidarité
et territoire pour objet d'augmenter les
crédits attribués à laallocation pour
demandeurs d'asile afin de prendre en
compte les effets de l'inflation et
d'annuler la baisse de 7 % présenté par
le gouvernement par rapport au crédit
2023 laallocation pour demandeur d'asile
créant 2015 n'a pas vu son barê
revaloriser depuis cette date l'accueil
des bénéficiaires de la protection
temporaire fuyant le conflit en Ukraine
depuis février 2022 a illustré un
constat partagé par les acteurs de
l'accompagnement des personnes en
demande d'asile depuis plusieurs années
à savoir le fait que le niveau de cette
allocation est insuffisant pour
permettre aux personnes ne disposant pas
d'autres ressources ce qui est le cas de
la plupart des personnes en demande
d'asile de subvenir à leurs besoins
élémentaires en effet en application du
Code de l'entrée du séjour des étrangers
du droit d'asile ces les bénéficiaires
de la protection temporaire ont reçu la
D complétée par un montant additionnel
qui est'est normalement délivré
qu'opersne en demande d'asile de
bénéficiant pas d'un hébergement pine
malgré la perception de Lada et de son
montant additionnel les personnes
bénéficiaires de la protection
temporaire sont némoins nombreuses à
avoir rencontré des difficultés à
subvenir à leurs besoins cette
revalorisation de laallocation pour
demandeur d'asile n'aura pas pour effet
de remédier entièrement à l'insuffisance
de cette allocation elle permettra
cependant aux personnes en demande
d'asile et bénéficiaires de la
protection temporaire qui la touche de
ne pas voir leur capacité à s'acheter
des produits alimentaires et d'autres
produits de première nécessité diminuer
de Man significative en conséquence de
la hausse des prix notamment pour
l'alimentation afin de gager cette
augmentation du budget du programme 303
immigration et asile dans le respect des
règles prévues par la loi organique
relative à la loi des finances il est
proposé de prélever ces
39682000 € au programme 104 intégration
et accès à nationalité française via son
action numéro 11 accueil des étrangers
primaux arrivant et c'est au profit de
l'action numéro 2 garantie de l'exercice
du droit d'asile du programme 303
immigration et asile il convient de
noter que la proposition de mouvement de
crédit est uniquement formelle afin de
respecter les règles budgétaires notre
intention n'est pas de ponctionner un
programme et nous appelons le
gouvernement à lever ce
gage le 868
monsieur çait oui merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues notre groupe également propose
de revaloriser l'aide pour les
demandeurs d'asile la laada ça a été dit
là expliqué précédemment mais quand même
he c'est cette allocation n'a pas été
son barê a pas été revalorisé depuis
2015 et on est en
2023 et tout le monde sait ici que
évidemment pour les demandeurs d'asile
l'inflation est là et on sait tous ici
qu'il y a une augmentation du nombre de
demandeur d'asile donc c'est pourquoi
nous proposons d'augmenter les les les
crédits pour des subvenir à des besoins
élémentaires une question de dignité et
et je rappelle quand même que la plupart
des demandeurs d'asile nont pas le droit
de travailler donc à partir de là du
point de vue de leurs ressources sur des
biens de première nécessité ou des
produits alimentaires je pense que là il
y a il y a un devoir d'humanité qui est
tout à fait à l'opposé de précédents
amendements qui ont été déposés par le
sénateur du rassemblement
national le 724 madame Nara sigin
merci monsieur le Président cette
amendement du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain s'inscrit dans
le prolongement des amendements
précédents il propose ég ement
d'augmenter les crédits alloués à la
location pour demandeurs d'asile qui
sont de nouveau en baisse dans ce projet
de loi de finance pour 2024 de 467
millions d'euros en 2022 puis 314
millions d'euros en 2023 les crédits
alloués pour 2024 sont de nouveau en
baisse et sont prévus à hauteur de
293,9 million d'euros cette baisse ne
nous paraît pas réaliste alors certes
l'activité de l'OFPRA a connu une
accélération notable grâce à un renfort
de ses effectifs ce qui réduit
mécaniquement la durée de ver ement de
laada par demandeur d'asile et donc son
montant montant global pour autant les
bénéfices de l'accélération du
traitement des demandes d'asile risque
d'être annulé par l'augmentation
attendue du nombre de demandeurs asile
en
2024 et à minima cela plaide pour une
stabilité des crédits de laada c'est le
sens de cet amendement qui propose
d'abonder les crédits de l'ADA à hauteur
de 20 millions d'euros merci Avid de la
commission pour ces trois
[Musique]
amendements alors habit général sur les
trois amendements sur le sujet du
montant de laallocation pour demandeur
d'asile comme nous l'avons dit dans la
discussion générale le montant de laada
apparaît sous-estimé en 2024 en effet la
baisse de 21 millions prévu par rapport
à 2024 est excessivement optimiste tout
d'abord elle s'appuie sur un
raccourcissement des délais de
traitement des demandes d'asile qui ne
sont pas réalistes ensuite elle
n'intègre pas suffisamment la forte
hausse prévue des demandes d'asile en
2024 nous ferons les comptes en fin
d'année prochaine les amendements
identique 680 et
868 propose de rajouter 40 millions au
budget de Lada pour compenser la baisse
prévue en 2024 pour intégrer les effets
de l'inflation il est vrai que le
montant de Lada est aujourd'hui modeste
pour ses bénéficiaires en particulier
dans un contexte de forte inflation mais
nous ne sommes pas en mesure de faire
plus en particulier au regard de la
hausse du nombre de demandeurs d'asile
je demanderai donc le retrait amendement
724 propose de revenir sur la baisse
prévue du budget de laad en 2024 en
ajoutant 20 millions je partage comme
vous l'avez compris l'esprit de cet
amendement pour les raisons évoquées
mais euh au regard de la proposition de
rejette crédit de la mission je
sollicite nmoins son
retrait madame la ministre euh donc
défavorable sur les trois amendements
donc je vous réponds en premier sur le
680 et le 868 donc effectivement
défavorable à cet amendement car le barê
de la location pour demandeurs d'asile
Lada est défini donc par le décret
l553-2 du cza il est par ailleurs faux
d'indiquer que le barê de la DA n'a pas
été revalorisé depuis 2015 le montant
journalier additionnel qui s'élevé
initialement à 4,20 € a été revalorisé
une première fois en 2017 à 5,40 € puis
une seconde fois à 7,40 € en 2019 pour
tenir compte des besoins des demandeurs
d'asile bénéficiaires le barê de laada
prend en compte les ressources de
l'intéressé son son mode d'hébergement
et le cas échéant les prestations
offertes par son lieu d'hébergement et
donc il me semble pas souhaitable afin
enfin d'opposer les montants de laada et
le financement des politiques
d'intégration des bénéficiaires de la
protection inter nationale tel que vous
le proposez et puis je réponds à
l'article euh pardon à l'amendement 724
défavorable encore une fois car les
dépenses prévues par laad en 2024 est
construite sur la base d'hypothèses
prudentes la DO inscrite pour la D au
projet de loi de finan 2024 s'élève à
million2 dont 6,3 millions de frais
gestion de l'OFI en 2024 le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile devait poursuivre sa
hausse la prolongation de la tendance
récente tant à une prévision de l'ordre
de 160000 demandeurs d'asile en 2024
soit près de à peu près plus 10000
demandes environ plus 7 % par rapport à
2023 défavorable donc sur les TR
monsieur
dux
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais réagir rapidement à ces trois
amendements qui vont dans le même sens
c'est-à-dire donner plus d'argent des
Français au demandeurs d'asile dont on
sait je le rappelle que 80 % d'entre eux
sont finalement déboutés donc c'est une
prime à l'immigration clandestine que
nous proposent les groupes de gauche et
d'extrême gauche dans un contexte
évidemment d'inflation pour les Français
qui souffrent je trouve que ces
amendements sont indécents c'est la
raison pour laquelle évidemment je
voterai
contre merci monsieur
soldelli
euh merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre excusez-moi mais je peux pas
vous laisser dire que les
Français l'étranger l'étranger l' mis à
contribution dans le casre des finances
publiques
ok ils sont
contributif donc moi ces discours là
franchement je veux pas les entendre
parce qu'ils ont aucune place ici les
étrangers y contribuent y compris à
l'état de nos finances publiques
nationales ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que Madame la
Ministre excusez-moi mais quand vous
nous dites pour 2024 vous êtes dans une
hypothèse
prudente ça manque de courage politique
VO je vous le dis très
sincèrement quand on fait la même
observation le même constat qu' a
l'inflation et qu' a un nombre de
demandeurs de de demandeurs d'asile
supérieur et qu'on dit qu'on est dans
une hypothèse prudente ça veut dire
qu'on assume pas ça veut dire qu'on n
pas le courage de sa
politique monsieur baroch
oui pour reprendre ce que vient de dire
mon collègue bien sûr que les étrangers
contribuent d'ailleurs on pourrait les
faire contribuer plus si je peux me
permettre tout simplement leur
permettant de travailler dès qu'ils sont
demandeurs d'asile d'ailleurs et de
cotiser aussi d'ailleurs et puis
d'ailleurs on a fait un certain nombre
d'amendement qui tendrait à montrer
d'ailleurs que si les étrangers en
situation irrégulière mais qui ont un
travail pouvaient être régularisé dans
leur activité dans leur travail ça
permettrait en fonction du nombre
d'étrangers bien entendu de résorber une
partie des problèmes L la retraite ça
nous aurait évité de faire contribuer
plus les Français les faire travailler
plus longtemps monsieur le sénateur
d'extrême droite et et ça nous aurait
permis aussi d'ailleurs de me dire que
c'est pas en accroissant la la misère
des uns qu'on va résoudre celle des
autres et que donc en l'occurrence il y
a aussi un autre moyen ce serait
d'augmenter le SMIC par exemple voilà
non mais c'est tout monsieur le sénateur
merci je vais mettre au voix ces
amendements d'abord 680 et 6 868 suite
avec une demande de retrait de la
commission défavorable pour le
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre pas
adopté je mets au voix le 724 avec une
demande de retrait de la commission un
avis défavorable de du gouvernement qui
vote pour
qui vote
contre je vais refaire qui vote
pour 7 10
11 11 c'est ça 11 qui votre
compte
il n'est pas
adopté deux amendements en discussion
commune le 869 monsieur
brossa merci merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre cet amendement vise à
accorder des moyens supplémentaires à à
l'OFPRA pour sa tâche de mairie des
étrangers c'est-à-dire pour la
délivrance des titres de séjour cet
amendement bénéficie d'un soutien
unanime des organisations syndicales la
crise sanitaire la dématérialisation des
procédures dans les préfectures et le
manque de ressources à louer au service
d'accueil des étrangers ont exacerbé le
temps d'attente pour avoir un titre de
séjour en raison de ces délais les
réfugiés se retrouvent souvent dans des
situations précaires avec des
conséquences directes sur leur accès à
l'emploi au logement aux droits sociaux
il est important de garantir un
traitement plus rapide des demandes de
titre de séjour afin de permettre aux
réfugiés de s'intégrer pleinement dans
la société française c'est le sens de
cet amendement merci le
722 madame Bruxell merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre nous
partageons la même préoccupation que nos
collègues du groupe communiste sur la
nécessité de garantir la meilleure
formation pour les agents de protection
de l'OFPRA si nous ne pouvons
qu'approuver le l'annonce et
l'amendement qui a été fait en en début
de cette séance sur l'augmentation du
nombre de postes à l'OFPRA il faut en
tirer les conséquences et pour que la
formation soit de qualité pour des
agents de l'OFPRA en plus grand nombre
il faut dès lors augmenter le budget de
formation initiale et continue dans les
mêmes proportions sinon de fait vous
serez en train de dégrader les
conditions de formation initial
etue des agents de lofpra Yann brossa le
disait à l'instant les demandes d'asile
sont de plus en plus nombreuses les pays
d'origine des demandeurs d'asile
évoluent pour parti au gré des conflits
qui naissent partout dans le monde les
motifs de persécution sont de plus en
plus spécifiques et tout ceci nécessite
un accompagnement en terme de formation
qui soit à la hauteur des besoins c'est
pour cela que le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain propose cet
amendement considérant qu'un montant
plus raisonnable de 500000 € peut
répondre à ses besoins de formation
merci avit de la
commission avis général sur ces deux
amendement la hausse du nombre de
demandes d'asile pose des défis à tous
les niveaux de notre politique d'im et
d'intégration c'est notamment le cas
pour l'ofra à qui on fixe des délais de
traitement particulièrement ambitieux
face aux demandes d'asile toujours plus
nombreuses s'il y a la rotation des
effectifs un mouvement social est
d'ailleurs en cours à l'OFPRA dans ce
contexte général la qualité des
décisions rendu par l'OF peuvent être en
outre menacé le sujet de formation des
agents abordés par ces deux amendements
est une question importante pour éviter
qu'un trop grand nombre de décisions
soit annulé ensuite par la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile il faut
garder à l'esprit que les décisions en
cause ont des conséquences majeures pour
la vie des personnes la somme proposée
dans le premier amendement est néanmoins
très élevé plus raisonnable pour
l'amendement 722 mais pour les deux je
demande le
retrait avis du gouvernement euh
défavorable sur les deux madame la
sénatrice monsieur le sénateur donc
défavorable sur les les deux amendement
car les crédits de subvention pour
charge de servicees public de l'OFPRA
sont en progression de plus 3,4 million
d'euros par rapport à la loi de finance
de 2023 donc défavorable sur les deux je
mets au voix ces amendements avec une
demande de retrait de la Commission
défavoraable du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il est pas adopté 2è le 722 même
vote
je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote
contre n'est pas adopté deux amendements
en discussion commune le 860 monsieur
brossa merci monsieur le Président
Madame la la ministre cet amendement
vise à créer de nouvelles places
d'hébergement d'urgence pour les
demandeurs d'asile cet amendement vise à
répondre au manque crucial d'hébergement
pour les demandeurs d'asile rappelle que
la moitié de ceux qui ont droit à un
hébergement n'en ont pas aujourd'hui et
ainsi nous proposons la création de 2000
places d'hébergement supplémentaire en
Nuda précisément pour pour palier ce
manque nous sommes convaincus que les
les avancées qui sont présentes dans le
budget ne sont pas suffisantes
malheureusement pour répondre à la
demande le 723 mon madame naraassigin
n'est pas défendu je
mets l'avis de la commission
madame sur la lancée des années
précédentes il est prévu la création de
1500 places supplémentaires dans le
budget pour 2024 500 places en CAD 500
places en centre d'accueil et d'examen
des situations 500 places en centre
provisoire d'hébergement pour les
bénéficiaires de la protection
internationale qui sont vulnérable c'est
certain face à l'afflux croissant des
demandeurs d'asile le parc d'hébergement
disponible ne permet pas de loger chacun
cela peut être regretté car le logement
des demandeurs d'asile est le principe
applicable mais il est très difficile à
atteindre lorsque la France doit faire
face à 160000 demandes d'asile je
rappelle que le coût d'hébergement des
demandeurs d'asile représente déjà 1
milliard d'euros en 2024 ce sera donc
une demande de retrait sur ces deux
amendements avis du
[Musique]
gouvernement défavorable sur les deux
amendements car des efforts
considérables ont été effectués depuis
2017 pour augmenter les capacités
d'hébergement des demandeurs d'asile et
ces efforts seront poursuivis dans les
prochaines années donc dé favorables
pour les deux je mets au voix le 870 qui
vote
pour qui vote contre n'est pas adopté le
723 même
vote pas adopté amendement 872 monsieur
ba monsieur
Savoldelli merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
l'ONU a a chiffré à 2000 en Méditerranée
sur la seule année 2022 et quand on
regarde les chiffres qui peuvent même
être plus importants en tout cas depuis
2014 il y a eu 28000 morts en en
Méditerranée c'est des chiffres
évidemment terrifiants qui nous alertent
sur l'urgence à agir en matière de
sauvetage en mer ce qui est une
obligation d'ailleurs de de droit
international cela devrait être une
mission régalienne ça c'est l'opinion de
notre groupe pleinement assuré par
l'État mais de fait il ne l'assume pas
et c'est donc des associations
spécialisées qui agissent tel que la
Société nationale de sauvetage en mer la
SNSM ou encore SOS Méditerranée la
première étant reconnue d'utilité
publique depuis plus de 50 ans cependant
ces associations manque cruellement de
moyens face à ampleur de la catastrophe
humanitaire qui a lieu sous nos yeux le
ressources d'ailleurs repose presque
exclusivement sur des dons privés et dès
lors que l'État répond pas présent nous
estimons qu'ell doivent être encourager
pour le rôle indispensable de sauvetage
de vie humaine et donc nous proposons la
création d'un nouveau programme dédié je
vous remercie avis de la
commission la mort des migrants
naufragés en mer Méditerranée est une
tragédie elle résiste d'ailleurs non
seulement de la volonté de s'exiler de
ces personnes mais aussi d'un système
organisé par des filières criminelles
les abandonnant ensuite à leur triste
sort pour autant il me semble que la
présente mission n'est pas le bon
vecteur budgétaire pour la proposition
demande de
retrait avis du gouvernement euh
défavorable sur cet amendement et et
dieu sais que depuis Marseille je
connais le sujet euh par cœur
euh donc nous on considère que la
réponse aux enjeux de sauvetage en mer
nécessite avant tout une étroite
coordination à l'échelle européenne et
la France poursuit un dialogue euh et ça
je vous le garantis nourrit avec les ONG
de secours en mer qui opère en
Méditerranée notamment donc
défavorbles merci je mets au voix cet
amendement avec une demande de retrait
de la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre n'est pas
adopté deux amendements en discussion
commune
682 monsieur
bénaroche monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à créer un fond destiné
à l'accompagnement au suivi
psychologique et psychiatrique des
personnes exilées arrivant sur le
territoire français santé mentale et
plus particulièrement la souffrance
psychique de nombreux événements nous le
montrent est un angle mort des
politiques publiques concernant les
personnes exilé pourtant lors de la
prise en charge des primau arrivants les
professionnels constatent que les
personnes exilées sont atteête de
troubles psychiques multiples en effet
de nombreuses personnes exilées
subissent de leur situation
prémigratoire à leur arrivée de
multiples situations traumatisantes les
violences ayant causé leur départ les
ruptures souvent brutales que cela
occasionne et le parcours d'exil
lui-même semé de violence et de pertes
cause des troubles psychiques graves
renforcé par la grande précarité sociale
et administrative vécu à l'arrivée la
forme la plus courante de ces troubles
est le syndrome psychotraumatique cette
affection complique les témoignages
devant l'OMF ou la CND notamment en
raison des troubles de la concentration
et de la mémoire qui affectent la
capacité des demandeurs d'asile de
mettre en récit leur parcours ces
derniers peuvent oublier jusqu'au prénom
de leurs enfants le stress des
entretiens décuple généralement ses
effets demp face à ce phénomène
plusieurs organismes ont signalé la
multiplication des cas de suicide et
demande la création d'un suivi
psychotraumatique de ces personnes dès
leur première mise en relation avec les
centres d'accompagnement c'est donc le
sens de notre amendement le fond que
nous proposons de créer financerit
l'emploi des professionnels de santé
tant psychologue que psychiatre
spécialisés dans la prise en charge des
pathologies traumatiques au sa de
centres gérés par l'État et d'organismes
associatifs habilités à prendre en
charge les personnes
exiler le 728 madame Nara sigigin
oui merci monsieur le Président il y a
quelques semaines lors du projet de loi
immigration et intégration nous avions
proposé d'interdire le placement en
rétention des personnes en situation
handicap ce qui incluait les personnes
souffrant de troubles mentaux et bien
que les centres de rétention ne soient
pas adaptés à la rétention des personnes
en situation de handicap notre
amendement avait été rejeté et donc en
guise de repli nous proposons avec notre
collègue husseain Bourgi et les membres
du groupe social écologiste et
républicains euh de doter chacun des
cras d'un professionnel de santé mentale
comme vient de le dire mon collègue
benaroche euh selon l'OMS les personnes
migrantes au regard de leur parcours de
vie peuvent être exposé à divers
facteurs de stress qui nuisent à leur
santé mentale euh et si ces personnes
obtiennent un titre de séjour une fois
arrivé en France euh ell bénéficient
d'un suivi de soins psychologique et
psychiatrique il doit en être de même
pour les personnes déboutter de leurs
demande et frappé d'une obligation de
quitter le territoire français
c'est pour cela que afin que les
étrangers atteints de troubles
psychologiques et psychiatrie puissent
être encadré et suivi le temps de leur
rétention nous souhaitant permettre le
recrutement de 26 ETP de psychiatres
pour que chacun des 26 cras de France
soit doté d'un professionnel de la santé
mentale avis de la
commission s'agissant de la santé
psychologique des personnes migrantes
oui ces troupes posent des difficultés
importantes je suis assez sensible à
l'idée de renforcer l'accompagnement
psych pologique car je pense que c'est à
la fois dans l'intérêt de ces personnes
et de la société mais soyons également
pragmatique assurer un accompagnement
psychologique sérieux nécessite de
maîtriser les flux migratoires c'est la
même chose que pour l'intégration
d'ailleurs autrement c'estes missions
impossible ce sera une demande de
retrait sur les deux amendements avis du
gouvernement défavorable sur les deux
donc je répondre très très rapidement
sur le 682 donc défavorable euh parce
que la santé mentale est une priorité et
vous avez raison de le rappeler porter
de longues dates dans la politique
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile et
d'intégration des réfugiés comme en
témoigne je vous le précise la
publication d'un plan dédié aux
vulnérabilités en mai 2021 et sur le le
deè c'est le 728 pardon donc défavorable
aussi je précise juste qu'une unité
médicale existe déjà dans chaque donc
défavorable sur les deux monsieur
moi deux petites réflexions la
première vis-à-vis du
rapporteur s'il y a des gens qui
arrivent dans qui subissent des des des
des troubles euh psychologiques ou ou
des traumatises psychologiques ou
psychiatrique bien entendu que il faut
ils sont ici sur notrre territoirees ça
n'a rien à voir avec le fait qu' on
augmente ou qu'on diminue les flux
migratoires mais en tout cas faut s'en
occuper faut les prendre en charge euh
je crois qu'actuellement euh le ministre
encore ce matin de l'Intérieur
expliquait en quoi certains événements
étaient liés à des troubles
psychiatriques ou psychologiques je
pense qu'il faut en tirer les
conséquences et les conclusions et en
particulier donc Madame la Ministre les
conclusions tiré c'est que c'est bien
gentil qu'il y a un plan voilà je le
disais tout à l'heure parol et parol
comme on dit dans le midi mais enfin une
fois qu'on a le plan madame la ministre
excusez-moi de vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
il y a pas de financement qui existe
donc mettant en place les financements
et à partir de ce moment-là on pourra
dire qu'il y a un début de mise en œuvre
du plan donc j' on a une situation
présente qui présente une urgence voilà
cette situation présente faut la traiter
maintenant non obstant toute euh
idéologie euh de l'immigration qu'on
puisse avoir merci je vais mettre au
voix l'amendement 682 avec une demande
de retrait de la commission défavorable
pour le gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
le 728 même
vote même vote pas adopté deux
amendements identiques le
681 monsieur
benaroche monsieur le Président le
présent amendement du groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire vise à ouvrir
les cours de français aux personnes
étrangère exclus du parcours
d'intégration du contrat d'intégration
républicaine la loi
2016-274 du 7 mars 2016 relatif au
droits des étrangers en France a créé le
contrat d'intégration républicaine
contrat conclu entre l'État français et
tout étranger non européen admé au
séjour en France il offre un parcours
personnalisé d'intégration comprenant
notamment une formation linguistique en
langue française les structures chargées
des enseignements de français langue
étrangère rencontent chaque année nombre
de personnes étrangères dans
signiliataire de ce contrat ayant des
besoins importants d'apprentissage de la
langue française la nonmaîtrise de la
langue constitue un frait important à
leur insertion en France renforçant leur
précarité sociale et leur don d'accès au
droit face aux démarches administratifes
je pense que tout le monde ici en
conviendra le présent amendement prévoit
donc un titre d'expérimentation une
ouverture de l'accès à la formation
linguistique à un public étranger non
siliataire du CR du contrat afin de
mieux prendre en compte ses besoins et
de pouvoir les objectiver dans le cadre
de cette expérimentation un amandement
de crédit supplémentaire sur ce besoin
pourra ainsi à travailler en
concertation avec les fédérations des
structures
concernées
le 871 il est
défendu avis de la
commission voilà nous avons constaté que
nos collègues députés ont eu la même
idée pour les mêmes montant et
l'amendement concerné a été repris par
le texte transmis au Sénat par le
gouvernement ces amendements sont donc
satisfaits demande de retrait avis du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
donc défavorable à cet amendement car
une offre de formation linguistique est
d'ors et déjà proposée aux étrangers non
signataires du contrat d'intégration
républicaine c'est hier qui le souhaite
sur l'ensemble du territoire donc
défavorable sur les deux merci je mets
au voix ces deux amendements identiques
avec une demande de retrait de la
commission défavorable pour le
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre n pas adopté mes chers collègues
nous allons procéder au vote des crédit
de la mission immigration asile et
intégration figurant à l'état B je n'ai
été saisi d'aucune demande d'explication
de vote à l'expiration du délai limite
je vous rappelle que la commission des
finances est défavorable à l'adoption
des crédits de cette mission je mets au
voix les crédits de la mission qui vote
pour qui vote
contre n pas
adopté nous allons procéder à l'examen
des amendements pourant sur les
objectifs et des indicateurs de
performance de la mission immigration
asile et intégration figurant à l'état
jamendement
726 présenté par Madame Nara sigin oui
si ça vous convient monsieur le
Président je vais vous présenter les
trois amendements 726 727 et
725 en même temps il s'agit de demande
d'indicateurs pour une meilleure
évaluation pour les années à venir de
cette mission budgétaire et donc trois
trois types d'indicateurs différents le
premier dans l'amendement 726
concernant l'accès aux formations
linguistique on sait que les étrangers
aujourd'hui ont beaucoup de difficultés
à accéder à des formations linguistiqu
avec des centres de formation et
d'examens qui sont saturer parfois
éloigné de leur domicile ce qui rend
cette formation peu compatible avec les
exigences de la vie professionnelle et
donc nous proposons des Indicateur sur
le délai d'attente sur le nombre
d'étrangers primo arrivant bénéficiirees
d'une formation linguistique et sur le
coou moyen euh d'une formation
linguistique par bénéficiaire le
l'amendement suivant 727 fait écho à
l'amendement 528 défendu tout à l'heure
euh concernant les personnes avec des
difficultés en situation de handicap et
des difficultés de santé mentale il
s'agit là d'avoir un indicateur sur le
nombre de personnes particulièrement
vulnérables placé en cras et donc
situation d'handicap atteinte de
maladies graves souffrant de troubles
psychiatriques placés sous tutelle qui
sont infermés en rétention et enfin euh
le 3è amendement concerne la la question
des délais de délivrance il y a eu un
rapport d'information des députés cé
Dupont et Mathieu Lefèvre qui indique
que les retards se traduisent par des
délais importants du détablissement
important d'établissement des tytres de
séjour par des difficultés accrues
d'accès au logement social et par un
délai supplémentaire par pour la
délivrance de carte vital ou
l'impossibilité de fournir les actes de
naissance des enfants lors de
l'inscription à l'école et c'est pour
cela que nous demandons un nouvel
indicateur à ce
sujet la commission avis de la
commission sur ces trois
amendements la commission n'est pas
favorable à créer des indicateurs
nouveaux nous considérons qu'il en
existe déjà et donc c'est un retrait
pour les trois
amendements madame la ministre euh donc
défavorable sur les les trois
amendements donc sur le 726 une courte
explication euh donc défavorable à cet
amendement qui instaure un nouvel
indicateur car l'efficience de la
formation linguistique est déjà mesurée
au sein des projet annuel de performance
sur le
727 défavorable aussi donc cet
amendement crée encore un nouvel
indicateur et je tiens juste à rappeler
que les personnes particulièrement
vulnérables bénéficient d'ors et déjà de
mesures alternative au placement en
centre de rétention administrative tel
que l'assignation à résidence et donc
pour le 725 défavorable aussi à cet
amendement instaurant un nouvel
indicateur car la préoccupation soulevée
nous semble satisfite à travers le
renforcement de + 16 ETP des effectifs
de l'OFPRA chargé de la délivrance des
documents d'état civil des bénéficiaires
d'une protection internationale BPI donc
défavorable sur les trois merci je mets
au voix l'amendement 726 avec une
demande de retrait de la commission
défavorable de la du gouvernement qui
vote pour
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
le 727 même voix même
vote 725 même vote et pas
d'adopté merci Madame